you know life can be stressful it can be
a real
chinese finger trap of a time and um
and one thing that 2020 taught us was
that you have to have peace of mind
that you can't let the outside influence
you constantly you have to find your own
peace
headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness
in the form of guided meditations in an
easy to use app
if you have not experienced meditation
is basically like loitering
inside of yourself real peacefully
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve
sleep boost focus and increase your
overall
sense of well-being sometimes throughout
my day when i've just done something
that's taken a lot of energy or taking
something out of me
i'll go find 10 minutes in headspace
myself
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
you deserve to feel happier and
headspace is a meditation made simple go
to headspace.com
theo that's headspace.com theo for a
free one month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every situation this
is the best deal offered right now
go to headspace.com theo today
and support the podcast you know today's
episode uh
man we just taped it and i'm i'm still
kind of um
just really hit me in the heart and uh
and honestly i don't even know why a
little bit
you know i don't even know why i feel
but it just filled me with a lot of
feelings um
and i think it made me it's making me
feel let me just try to think what i'm
feeling right now so just give me just a
second um
it made me feel like i can be a
it made me feel
like i can be a part
of something better is that what it made
me feel it made me feel
it made me feel like there is something
bigger going on out there that i'm
not in control of and that
whatever that bigger thing is that it um
it has good intentions i think honestly
that's what
uh what it made me feel um
you're gonna love today's episode uh
today's guest
is chris nikitch he is the first
down syndrome uh human ever to finish
an ironman marathon he's here today
gracing us with his presence
him and his father nick nikitch are here
today uh and i hope you will enjoy this
episode
uh be patient there's um you know
there's some communication that
that takes some time to kind of build
but um
but this was uh this was one of the best
uh hour or so
amount of times i'd ever spent in my
[Music]
sit and life you my stories
[Applause]
people complain about everything yeah
but i'm telling them
look you guys you guys stop talking like
that
yeah no sportswear yeah yeah
you gotta work hard you gotta work hard
if you work hard you succeed in life
who taught you that oh god and your
dad's here today
yes what's his name look nick
nickitsch yes nick nickitch is he a role
model
yes what's another role model that you
have
perseverance perseverance is a role
model
oh interesting can when you're competing
do you feel like you're competing
against yourself
to make yourself better or do you feel
like you're competing against the other
competitors what is it like for you to
compete
in iron man is it feel like you're
competing against yourself
or against other people i'm copying
against myself and other peers as well
i was better than yesterday
i wanted to stay active
um too straightforward
to stay keep going forward yeah when
you're
what is the toughest part when you're
doing the ironman what is the toughest
part like was there a moment that you
felt like you couldn't go anymore
was there a moment that felt like maybe
you wouldn't be able to do it
what were some tough moments like um one
of my top
moments was the pain
the pain where where was the pain like
the butt the lower back
i had to see upwards by uh
one of the people at the
oil became soft they're
making a new bike
so i could lean forward
oh you got a new bike that helps you
lean forward yeah
and does that make it easier to compete
yeah
when you were doing the iron man was
there a certain mile where you wanted to
give up maybe
so at some point also about 13
when to hit the roar at mile 13 yeah wow
that's early in the race right no that's
in the marathon
oh that's in the marathon only um
i knew that the pair is coming
the pain pain's coming i knew that
my dad called me hugged me he came and
hugged you
yeah and what did he say he said what's
going through
the paintings on the dreams and the
shirts between and then you just kept
going
yeah i found my way through
when you're competing do you know that
you have do you know that you have a
disability or do you
can do does it feel on the inside like
you have a disability or it doesn't feel
like it
uh rfid spirit
is called um down syndrome
connect disorder raspberry
does it feel like you have it or
or does it feel different inside of you
or does it feel
normal inside of you um i have it now
it feels that
i need someone to kiss my heart
and i could be my woman oh you need
someone to touch your heart huh
yeah that might cure it huh yeah
um have you had uh have you been in love
in your life
once um
when i crossed my bike
i saw i saw her that's a smoking heart
a smoking hot person smoking hot woman
she came and helped you
oh yeah
dad are you buying this one i don't buy
this song no i'm not buying it
[Laughter]
you're just making stuff up i remember
i'll tell you my story for
i'll tell you a story from me chris i
remember chris kicked his dad just now
i'll tell you a story from me chris when
i was young i remember i was maybe like
seven years old
and i was in texas and i went outside
and there was a girl by a stream and she
was getting like um
she was just getting like a bucket of
water out of the river or stream
and that was the first time in my life i
ever felt like i was in love with a girl
i just remembered i never had felt that
before
and then i saw her and something about
her made me think that i loved her and i
felt like oh i'm in love with her
did you do you remember the first time
you had a moment like that where you
felt like
attracted to a woman like that yeah
um
i always had the mexican
with my dad the orlando magic game yeah
and i saw pre-dancer
yeah and uh she's in my photos
and um
and she was uh
attractive she was so
smoking hot yeah
cute um ourselves to say
she's the most absolute
best
oh so she really took your heart away
huh she didn't take my heart
yeah what did you ask her i decided
you're fraught with me
yeah and what did you ask her i was
thrown back yeah baby boy
you actually asked her something didn't
you and
my aunt i said
what's going on date nice
and horrible i suck
sir and then
in a few moments i looked
in the eyes of a beautiful woman
stay right there yeah if someday i
said will you marry me
oh wow you went straight to marriage huh
yeah strong move
um
what is she saying she's like sure wow
right there
at the magic when i go home tonight
i said to my mom mom
found a woman it's just like
she myself um
she's quite older i'm like
i don't care i don't care her age
i don't care how old she is
and i said
mom i accidentally
and it's just like for real i'm like
i'm getting serious and then
she said what makes you want to make a
move on this woman
good question mom
i've got no choice but take my woman
there
and then one day i said
mom i actually made me and then
my mom said
where did she come from unlike a family
a family her family told her
that when that conference
her father her father gave me a
profession to meet his daughter
her father what i wanted to get precious
oh a present blessing impressive oh you
had to get the blessing from the father
from her father such a man's daughter
so did you do it yeah no you didn't
now you're making stuff up everything
was true up till that point
at some point the mom
knows me and she said
are you there man or somebody made my
daughter
he's a freaking magic dancer okay now
let's stop because now you're making
stuff up
so he's going to cut this out but it was
a good story though
he'll tell you a story so that was the
first woman that you felt like you
really fell for huh yeah
yeah tell them what you said when you
saw rachel
on instagram i'm gonna tell her that
tell him he wants to know that stuff oh
okay so you saw rachel on instagram what
did you say to me i saw
rachel and who is rachel a girl
yeah okay she uh she knew she's tampa
oh nice she's filming as strong as far
up
she's what this was uh runner-up miss
florida oh she's miss runner-up miss
florida wow beautiful and what did you
say when you saw her
i said that's the wrong that's the one
yeah but i figured she's got autism
whispering difficult she has autism
so it makes things difficult
yeah is she able to communicate
yes oh she's amazing she sounds really
cool
yeah but she says smoking hard
but she doesn't understand that's for me
enough that's because she has autism so
she's you got to teach her how to get
more social social social
well i bet she i uh do you guys have
plans to maybe go out sometime
no i don't know nothing you know well
you guys get together all the time
we always get to go do stuff she was at
your house for two days this week
she's in my house okay so there's
definitely a possibility there
what's harder for you to compete with
with to compete physically or to compete
with women trying to meet women what's a
tougher obstacle in the world do you
think
i say our competition it's hard huh
you know it's not hard but
it's called easy simple favor
is a woman who enters into my world
she must be the one oh i love it i like
your attitude i'm the same way if i see
a woman
i fall in love with her every eye do see
a woman she must be hot oh yeah
that's a good
it's a good attribute man i like it it
was a classic bike
i knew that this hot vlog was
directly come to me
oh i see it's almost like a story out of
like a
asap's fable or something yeah yeah i
like that
she pulled her sword out she pulled a
sword out
sore sore
what pulled one out she poured out her
soul
oh she poured her pour down her soul
[Music]
yeah there's some remarks i think we all
i think as
men we all have that like it's hard with
women
it's hard that's nice for me oh okay my
bad man
because i'm keeping asking about your
women to be my date
hey look and if and what did dad say
whenever you were having trouble at that
uh
at the halfway point of the marathon
what was the options
the sixth place well it's me
you're basically 73 it's the dream baby
and
he said okay there's time to get the
rice
yeah that's the next obstacle huh yeah i
love that
but you must feel pretty confident in
yourself if you're able to
to to take on an iron man and finish
and then if you have the next obstacle
in your life maybe is to meet a woman
and
and settle down i bet you feel very
confident do you
yeah um
am i trying 20s on my life
i knew that the next time
if i do the next iron man if i
come in on time then i don't
finish life they're going to be a
smoking hotline
i love it my tail and
the easterns i'm gonna grab my mario
and then basically my stuff
could be at her hotel oh i can i see
and then my woman could take
me back to your hotel
i like it you got a whole plane
sour safe
good dress and then
basically like
there's no way any woman
my primary army but
i definitely put my own underwear on
but as you poured
on my pants
and then the belt
then she's going to help me
with the dresses oh she's going to help
you with your
dress shirt yeah oh that's romantic yeah
i like that's because oh you can't do
your own buttons
wow doesn't have the fine motor skills
but you can do an iron man
yeah yeah but he can't tie his own shoes
good thing
they don't have any buttons on the iron
man oh
and i put on a dresser
she buttons and
she puts the tie on
she puts the jacket on
and then she must say then we're all
going off
honey where are you going honey where
and where are you guys going to go i'm
going to remember
to a nightclub yeah okay i like that and
then all
the family the coaches
the peers repeated that club oh i love
this third time
i was yeah and then when i arrived
the doors could be closed the nights are
off
and um and we're gonna have a proper
spinners
yeah i probably dk yeah we're gonna have
like
drinks we've got chipotle yeah scarce
whiskey
appetizers wine beer snacks
appetizers yes sugar yes
dancing yeah yeah
am i am i reserve a table only for two
so don't distract me yeah and so your
dad won't be at that table well i know
she might die with me because he's gonna
be with my mom yeah
he's going to be with your mom and
you're going to be with your lady
this is a fairy tale i love it though
and you can make i i believe you can
make it happen do you
yeah i love that i love your confidence
if you sell stuff online if you're a
salesman a person that sells you know a
seller
sales seller selling if you've ever
lived in a cellar lived underground if
you lived in a bunker
if you have ever uh worked with um
time capsuling then uh no that's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying is
ship station if you need to if you if
you're trying to sell something you're
selling things online
and you you're going to paypal and
you're printing off the different things
and you're losing your mind you're
yelling at your mother she's doing it
for you
and you don't even know if it's your
real mother then that's the problem
the solution is ship station no matter
where you're selling amazon etsy or your
own website ship station
brings all your orders into one simple
interface
the world of mark of selling is online
now
you can't even go anywhere because
people dang you know curse you out for
unmasking there's a good reason
shipstation is the number one choice of
online sellers if you're using usps
fedex ups they can handle it all
get 2021 off to a great start and
support the podcast by visiting
shipstation.com just use my offer code
t-h-e-o to get a 60-day free trial
that's two months of free trial and
my god that's two months of no hassle
stress free shipping
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page
and type in t-h-e-o that's
shipstation.com inner offer code theo
ship station make ship happen
today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
it is the anti-procrasti
sipper flow state now comes in a bottle
check it out it's a good coffee
alternative magicmind.co
use promo code theo for ten percent off
is your body right as you dick right
those are questions men ask themselves
and have since the beginning of time
if you look on cave walls indian walls
they got people in there drawing decent
wieners and that's what i'm telling you
about
bluechew.com offers
men a performance enhancement for the
bedroom or cave
or wherever you make love the chewables
from bluechew can be taken on a full or
empty stomach
have you a sandwich have you one of them
weiner uppers
and get at it no in person doctor visit
no awkward conversation no waiting in
line at a pharmacy
ships directly to your door it's that
discreet
dick help that's right
here's a great deal for you guys visit
bluechew.com and get your first order
free
when you use promo code theo let me help
lift you
lift that low nugget baby that weiner
just pay
five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w-dot-com
promo code theo you know terrence ross
plays for the orlando magic
yeah he does right he's a friend of mine
so next time you go to a game we will
have to have him come over and tell you
hello
he's a really special guy um
who are some athletes that you look up
to
i look up to ichikampo
who is it it's a combo i'm not jealous
mvp last year uh-uh from uh milwaukee oh
and how do you say his name again it's a
combo
it's a crimper yeah i never knew how to
pronounce it i've seen it written
yeah he's exceptional but and who's
better than him
who's the boy from dallas that's your
favorite you can talk this yeah look at
dante's is dope
and every time you guys don't kiss chris
crosses eating compost
it's a couple days tanker it just kicks
out
tell him what you want to do with luca i
beat you i had a massive hobby
i love that i look i'll be a cheerleader
if you beat him i'll be the cheerleader
nope there must be a woman yeah okay
it's not woman it's gonna be smoking hot
of course she is man it was i do beat
you guys doctors
that i take my woman but if he beats me
i'm gonna stick to my woman though okay
i love it man
wow you really you're such a uh
do you know how your parents met each
other like their first date
yeah 34 years 34
minutes and they've met in minnesota
yeah
what was your what was the first date
that your dad took your mom on do you
know
yeah um he checked on my armpit hand
and he said first you made her
the way that i lost my woman on a first
date nick is that true
so i met my wife in a nightclub in
minnesota
on a saturday night we talked a little
bit i went home
next day i called her from new york
that's where i lived
and she told me she was going to marry
me wow
so i see where this fairy tale really
hits close to home
yeah look i need your right foot down
the road
you ready i know you think so yeah
i'm freaking ready look i'm gonna be
22 next year i'm gonna say this dad
did you mess with my life i'm gonna get
a woman you stop it
yeah when i get my woman i'm gonna see
my girl i'm crazy
she's our best friend you're gonna tell
dad to step aside huh
yeah stop stop stop hitting me
um do you
what are some things in your life that
are tough what are some things about
the disability you have that are tough
that people wouldn't
know are tough they
couldn't know what i'm
capable of um
besides i couldn't do much
but i told them
you didn't stop tell me what i killed
you
and then i told them to effectively
take their knee off take the what off
take the lid off um you need to
stop treating kids with the disabilities
wow if you don't succeed in life
then i can do it if
wow that's so amazing to hear um a lot
of people with disabilities don't have
the same mindset
as you i do you think people don't
give them an opportunity
do you think people look at you
and think you can't do it well
okay so people think i can do
but i say to them
look here are the basic
reasons the first reason is
if they can do it i can do it if there
is
i can work hard if they'll succeed
i can succeed i can be a better father
better husband with a wife
i love it what are so what are some
things that
like you mentioned earlier like buttons
are hard to do right yeah
what are some regular tasks that are
tough for you obviously you're an iron
man champion so
you can do anything in the world i
believe that and so do you
but what are some basic little tasks
that might be tough
okay so for instance
after my wife burns africa
so basically like thomas hughes
okay so tying your shoes is tough yeah
so let's talk about other stuff but
he wants to know what is unique about
down syndrome
that makes everything hard for you what
a give them three or four things that
make down syndrome hard
i definitely say per balance
poor balance oh poor balance yeah
interesting
why why do you think can you do you know
why poor balance
because we don't know why
right but tell them tell them like you
know how hard it is to learn how to ride
a bike how long did it take you to learn
how to ride
six years wow i'm not
freaking nice
what else is hard about downstairs um
okay low tone
low tone when you talk no long tone
muscles oh really
so what do you have to do to build
muscles but
i think there's stronger how much harder
do you have to work to build the same
muscles
five to ten times harder no way just to
build the same muscles
okay what else is hard for down syndrome
um
do they react to delayed reaction when i
cross my bike
i see smoking on yeah yeah
so reaction time is slow okay so when
you're riding your bike
you need quick reactions quick reaction
so
took a long time to learn how to react
fast enough like when you're
right now he can ride 28 miles an hour
you gotta have fast reactions to when
stuff pops up in front of you
that took a long time to learn how to do
wow
and did you do it did you learn by
actually riding a bike or did you take a
simulator
no actually writing actually writing
thousands of times around thousands
thousands and thousands one time i was
fighting in my neighborhood
and they said getting a car like
was driving and i was freaking fast
you were faster than the car no he was
going fast car was coming
so the car's coming and then
basically i was on the side of the car
cave
and when i saw the car i didn't actually
react fast and
i started speeding down the hotel
freaking neighborhood
i passed the freaking sign
limits and what happened and i
passed a freaking car and then in a
freaking car
put a horn and the person was like what
the hell
is that when you crashed and
when i got to the other side
i shot this hot blonde yeah
distracted
she distracted me you crashed your mic
i crossed my bike she hugged her boom on
the street
oh they ruined me yeah they ruined
everything man
he just went everything that dance
she's beautiful though huh yeah yeah
beautiful
smoking dogs yeah she
farts with a biker who fell
i forgot about i can relate man i think
about
i always think about girls girls make
girls are in girls influence a lot of
my behaviors i think most guys are that
way
yeah yeah you know um but not me
oh not you huh no i'm uh
i'm a humor i've got a
i've got a great taste of humor that's
true
and uh i'm another
um i'm a servant of god
who is still such a woman i like that
and smoking holidays yeah the nearly
come up to me
one by one and they say
chris why christmas
i like that i like that man
you're just like me man i think you you
and i are very excited
well when i was born they thought i had
down syndrome when i was born
and so i can really relate to uh i don't
know i think i just
feel sometimes i feel almost trapped
inside of myself
and i don't know if that's what your
life is like but sometimes
i feel like i i don't know i just feel
like trapped inside of myself
um what are now that you've completed an
iron man
is there a new goal or is it will you
come
continue to compete in iron man or do
you want to do professional bowling is
there something new
i won't be a professor golfer really and
i'll get married
our kids are freaking married oh yeah
golfers always get married they always
have chicks
yeah he just started his golf program
really go three years from now to be a
par golfer wow and
how does how is golf different in
competing
than iron man and triathlon because
i made this harder and i didn't take the
risk
of getting injured i was
still took off and made my woman is golf
easier
yeah got me cece
because when i get a fighter thomas
i've gotta take my woman she'll be right
there yeah she could be your caddy
okay a wife and one mother
and a mother yeah there's some look if i
could find a woman that could be all
three of those
i want that woman too yeah whenever i
make a good sock
she kisses me oh i like that
they're weird
everything goes in for a boy she kisses
me oh i like that
she sounds like a nice lady whoever she
is this is
nice yes i reported
out she's quite smoking hot keep smoking
hard babies
smoking hot smell stuff yeah whatever
everything is dark inside spaghetti
yeah i love that that's her nickname
smoking hot huh yeah yeah i like it
i would say you must heart you
must have a woman
there one of those i'm going to make you
yeah
now if you get married where would you
have uh the
the um what's the dinner called before a
marriage nick the night before what is
that or the
rehearsal dinner yeah where would you
have your rehearsal dinner what would be
a restaurant you would have it at
i definitely have it in hawaii
harley you knew where it is
pretty fancy yeah it's nice pretty fancy
for a smoking hot woman oh yeah who
could be your friend
yeah hawaii is a good place to fall in
love yeah
what does love feel like to you can you
do you have like when you think about
love
what does it feel like enough is like
hard moments kind nothing
a person who cares for me a person who
loves me though i love my mom
a person who um watched me
be a bad husband a person who
wants me to be a good father um
look when i have my own woman
then my woman could say
honey
how can we stop doing what we're doing
let me make out oh yeah
and yeah yeah you know hey i would say
watch you when
you call when you call back does
make out rhymes with sex christophe it
stop it hey it's normal man don't go
there
no you're normal i know hormones baby
hormones man they're wild um
what does it feel like when you are
about to start a race when you were
about to start the iron man
do you feel at peace or do you
feel aggression what do you feel like
if you're at a starting line how do you
feel
i feel like i'm in korea
i feel like i'm gonna talk to a family
what is it i'm sorry can you say it
included
part of the family oh wow i am uh
i'm in korea and
be part of summers that's what you feel
like at the starting line
yeah wow so there's a big sense of
inclusion for him and being in those
races
that's number one out of everything is
the enemy number one
of africa those people there feel like
you're brothers and sisters huh yeah
and when you're when you're going
through the iron man
do you ever have to help people up that
have fallen i have
and what does that feel like so
when that person who falls down
i got back there
i picked him up he said keep going
you're myself you almost around me
and keep going and
maybe you keep going
then looking down where i mean
saying my name is
up or down to my hero
it was up and down the stairs
um i just got a
big deal i got a studio
i got the world record
and best of all
i've been living a happy
healthy place i like your attitude
man it's so goal oriented um
do you do you feel tired like when i
feel tired
i feel like kind of
weak and i feel exhausted and i feel
thirsty
and i feel like i need a break
those are things that i feel like when i
feel tired
what do you feel like when you feel
tired
so when i feel tired
i quit um
when i'm exhausted
i can say suck it up
yeah um this is a i have a question for
your dad can i ask your dad a question
sure okay um nick so do you uh
is it hard to know when to push chris
and motivate
him and know when to
is it hard to know what his capabilities
truly are is it hard to know when
he he's being earnest about if he's had
if he's
too tired or not like i could imagine
that might be tough to kind of know is
has that been interesting to learn great
question because
he has learned how to manipulate all of
us
he has learned when when he wants
something how to
actually put on an act and so at first
when he hit that wall i would think oh
he's done
but then i started to test him a little
bit
and i realized that that was an act
and that he could keep going and so it
was a learning experience
and i've learned how to help him
mentally
overcome a lot of what's going on in
order to help him build a
strong mental attitude that helps him
fight through
um because as you can imagine everything
i've been told iron man
is 90 mental the body can handle so much
more than the mind can handle
so a lot of the training was mental it
was teaching him
how to overcome that mental pain
that hits you um and so for him tired is
pain
and so um i had to learn how to figure
out when that was real when it was and
how to deal with it
and it's been a fascinating journey the
last year uh teaching him mental
toughness
um he is as mentally tough as anybody
ever going to meet now
wow what he had to go through to do that
iron man
um you know he essentially went from a
14 mile
sprint which is you know what a lot of
people start out with
to a 140 mile iron man in about 10
months
which is unbelievable and he did it with
all kinds of obstacles uh including that
he can't ride arrow right which is a
downward position which is about 30
more efficient than the average person
he can't ride with clip-ons on his feet
he has to ride with flat
which is another 30 percent um
and then he crashed his bike in the
middle of the race so he had to
like stand up with the blood and the
pain he got bit by fire ants and so he
his legs were all swollen up throughout
the whole thing all of that
is about mental toughness physically he
was beat up and bruised and
everything and when he wanted to quit at
every stage he just got tougher and
tougher
and at mile 13 as he said when every
bone in his body every muscle ached
everything told him to quit
um he just toughened up and mentally the
whole year was about teaching him
mentally how to overcome those obstacles
and now i know that he can handle
anything in life because mentally
doesn't matter what hits him he's not
never going to quit he knows how to
fight through it
was he always like that or it's
definitely you've noticed something that
was learned
no it's something that's been learned in
the last year he was never like that
it's been and that's the good news right
for anybody
is that you can learn mental toughness
he learned
mental toughness in the last year you
must be so proud of him huh
i think he's amazing every day he just
surprises me by how tough he is how
resilient he is
um how much he learns you know and what
a great
attitude he has uh in terms of what he
does
and what i've noticed the greatest thing
of all
is the impact he's having on other
people love your baby
yeah he's changing lives man he's he's
showing people like me and my wife
who were devastated when he was first
diagnosed with down syndrome
for 20 years we thought he couldn't do
anything now
what he's showing the world is that
there's a whole world of possibilities
out there
so yeah i'm proud of him but but i'm
just so excited about
the the mission he has um to make a
difference in the world and to help
others like him and like us
boys said women's name who is right
there which one should it be
when you were on the bike oh they were
everywhere they came to see you because
they had kids with down syndrome and
they wanted to see it
wow um people came from everywhere
did they with their kids with down
syndrome and they wanted to see if this
was real
do you feel like uh you know i noticed
even just in my own life like um you
know like i had to work so hard and even
just in comedy to get uh
a foothold of my own you know and um
then at certain points you feel like god
has he wants you to be a part of a
mission or you know like
and it's natural i think to have those
those thoughts it's normal because
you're like
why has so much been and it's not a ton
but why have i been
focused on why is you know the light of
the world or whatever or
a journey of the world been kind of like
attached to me in some way
um i can only imagine that that
a lot of that kind of happens with uh
with chris uh
chris do you feel like god has a special
plan for you yeah
that's pretty cool huh yeah
to make sure that i need to get
a woman yeah yeah i think that's going
to happen easy
like so chris i know so what about
all of those social media posts from all
the moms and dads
with kids with down syndrome that you
read all the time what are they saying
those fives with thousands of
the same empty hero
two kids another kid can start
does that make you how does that make
you feel it feels
um like i inspired
everybody to recall about you ten times
higher
that's interesting man yeah you're
definitely an inspiration
um yeah i can't imagine what it's like
to feel like you're then like kind of
part of this bigger journey this bigger
picture journey of inspiring people
well i'll tell you we you know we
believe that god has his hand in this
one for chris
and he's using chris as a way to
give hope to a lot of others like him
and create a community of inclusion
and one because what chris is doing is
not just for down syndrome he's actually
creating a whole community around him
who people are volunteering and helping
and they're seeing how wonderful it is
to be part of
a community like that um and i tell
people
um if you don't believe that god had his
hand on this one
uh let me tell you a story you know
before november 7th in 2020
every full ironman in the world was
canceled right buddy
after november 7th every one was
cancelled
but november 7th when chris was doing it
it was the only one that was on
really the only one in the world you
guys had already booked that in advance
we booked it a year in advance and we
told everybody god's not going to let
this one get cancelled
wow and people said you're crazy they're
all canceled they're all being canceled
i said yes except this one god wants
chris to do something special in this
one
so he's going to make sure this one
doesn't get canceled and it didn't get
canceled and chris shocked the world and
so so the only one chris was registered
for is the only one that happened wow
oh that's powerful and then everybody
told us
he's not going to handle the water
because the waves are
so big and wild i said don't worry god's
going to calm the water that day
and then he said well you know he's
going to this i said don't worry god's
going to take care of it
and we're not scared chris were you
scared or not um
at first um
i knew that this happy birth
kept going yeah and how close is your
dad when you're actually racing do you
have someone that like
are racers allowed to have a assistant
with them yeah okay
for special olympics there's a guide
someone who's with them the whole time
okay so he had a guy dan grieb who's
been an angel sent to us to help him
through this
right and dan was like the perfect
person brought into his life
and then you know he had carlos um who's
also
um helped him carlos is a dan's a
business person in orlando carlos is a
federal judge
jennifer is an executive at disney these
are all people who came around him
who got brought to him who are the
perfect personality the perfect people
the perfect backgrounds to guide him
through this journey
and to help him do something something
big so
god had his hand in this the whole time
you know all that time that you've been
spending
looking for thing you've been maybe
looking for that you lost a contact lens
or you lost
uh half a can of butter beans somewhere
or you have a missing person you know
someone that's missing or you knew them
and now they're gone but hopefully
you'll find them
you know all that time you spent playing
your favorite mobile games on your phone
well you could have been winning money
and prizes
skills.com turns mobile gaming
into cash s-k-i-l-l-z
dot com literally has the greatest games
on the planet
and you'll possibly bump into me there
i'm currently hooked on
strike bowling if you like bowling and
strikes
skills makes it super easy to get
started they have games for everyone
classics like solitaire cube and 21
blitz
and new fun games like blackout
beginners play beginners experts play
experts if you're going to play games
you might as well win
cash it's totally legit players have won
over 2
billion dollars with a b new users
to skills use my promo code theo because
i got you double the cash that you start
playing with that's a promo code t-h-e-o
for double the cash to get started go to
skills
s-k-i-l-l-z dot com slash
theo that's s-k-i-l-l-z with a z dot com
slash t-h-e-o must be 18 or older terms
and conditions apply
not available in all states see website
for details
if you know me you know that i have
mental health issues
and that's who i am i'm basically a
little gary busey son
if there's something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
then i think this episode right here has
been really good for you
i also think that you can get help
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
this service is available for clients
worldwide there's a broad range of
expertise available
which may not be locally available you
may in some areas you got to go
underground you got to meet a gnome by a
root
you know and next thing you know you
back behind a dollar general and
somebody's huffing you out bro and they
said
it's for mental health and it's not
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily
you know i was going through a tough
time at one point many points but this
is a specific one
and i pulled my car over on the side of
the road and got me some better help
literally
got on a better help and within minutes
i was having a face time with my
counselor
visit betterhelp.com theo that's better
help help join over the million people
who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month
at betterhelp.com theo and now back to
the episode
i feel i think when i hear about your
story it makes me feel
can i tell you how it makes me feel it
makes me feel
when i hear about your story it makes me
feel like
like i can do things that maybe i'm
afraid to do you know
and it makes me feel like
there is a bigger
that there is a bigger purpose in the
world um
than just my own purposes and it makes
me feel excited
that's how you make me feel when i hear
about your story
um so thank you
yeah we uh
we bought a couple of shirts earlier
today one for myself and one for my
producer nick can you tell us about the
one percent better
sure i was really the concept
of working hard um
to be successful and to
start small um my
values for kids is that
stay small stay fit
use positive words
be in the moment and
um in this pain i can tell them they
speak pain
and i know that
yeah you're like martin luther chris man
i feel like
um so golf is next huh
yeah who should be worried out there
phil mickelson tiger woods who should be
scared
i would say afterwards yeah okay
and my wife said yeah why should i get
scared miss golf course
i'm like because
you're my wife and when i make
i'm not good size kiss me yeah
kiss me we all want love man that
that's that's pure love yeah we all do
it
and i told her and she said
she said awesome let me kiss
hey look that's not a look a kiss is a
good start
a kiss is a good start what is those
zips hey on the lips it's a good place
for a kiss man
are there any actresses that you see on
television that you think are cute
yeah i've seen actresses
cute awesome actresses
oh smoking heart which ones any show in
particular or movie in particular yeah
i would say um
all right in la
ncisla yeah oh ncisla which one which
one do you like
which one what's her name kenzie yeah
and then what about freaking for that
yeah what about chicago pd
or chicago pd which one do you like
haley yeah
she's quite freaking sparkly
a lot of beautiful ladies out there yeah
looking um towards me saying
when you crush that i'm in hawaii
you gotta come up because i've got a
podcast
yeah only one man no one knows no one
else huh
nope just you and her in a podcast i
like it that's her daddy
i love it look she's my woman
this is my pure knife and no one would
we should go on a double date sometime
definitely
we'll get two ladies and take them
somewhere fun uh
maybe i'm thinking like have you ever
been to a water park before
i have do you like it yeah
maybe we could do a water park or
oh go-karts do you like yeah and other
puppies yeah bumper cars
that would be fun stopping oh on the
go-karts
yeah yeah it's fun um what else could we
do on our double date you think
where could we go today i think we
should go to uh basically restaurant
it'd be romantic yes get some candle
light
yeah yeah guys afterwards yeah yeah
maybe a couple roses on the table for
the ladies yeah
a little bit of champagne a little
carpet yeah
yeah a little scotch damn okay
dang bro if i have too much scotch i'll
have down syndrome bro i have too much
right now
it's sometimes kissing yeah finish with
some kissing man
dad gets nervous when you say it i think
it's awesome
um i'm trying to think of any other
message that you want to leave our
listeners with chris
okay any any any positive message you
want to leave our listeners with
sure um and the message
is simple for kids
by saying
start faith with iron man
whatever your iron man is start training
for it huh yeah
man well i just feel so lucky chris that
that you came here today
can i can we be friends from now on is
that okay yeah
okay cool man i want you to meet my
friend terence ross who plays for the
orlando magic he will love you okay he's
really cool he's very tall though
okay but you could probably beat him
yeah i think he would that's cool
that'll be a lot of fun and if i be
here i'll be going to um
like if like if i be here
i go
to the nba all star game i'm in i
believe that
but if you beat me then i'm not going
okay okay i thought i'd be here you're
going he's gone
i'm going out all right chris let's
close it out with um
there's one thing that that's kept him
motivated
and on task for a year working hard
and it's his dream yeah okay chris
because you know he's referring back to
it so chris
tell him your dream the one you talk
about every day that you see on your
board every day
tell them your dream and why you work so
hard and first tell me
what is your board tell them about your
board so
the board has scores the
board has the dreams
the board has other workouts that i'm
doing
and where is the board in my bedroom so
you see it every day
yeah and do you have to wake up at a
different time each day do you like to
wake up at the same time what do you
like to do
i usually wake up in the morning and i
look at my dream
in a dream would say
hide on task
buy a house buy a car
may smoking hot vlog be a part golfer
give your dreams right there every day
so you wake up and see your dreams
yeah and then you go get them but i'm
kidding so much
dad you can't make decisions for me
i've gotta make my own decision so
please dad
give me that life right now and he said
why you're too young i'm like
where's my dad i'm not young
second floor i'm a man
don't be easy
if you don't give my woman i'm moving
now
you remind me of a professional wrestler
it's so funny chris because
it's so funny the way you talk because i
will often just go off
and tell stories that i like to tell so
it's so funny sitting here with you and
watching somebody else be
do it it's so refreshing to not have to
be the one to do it
um but i love the idea of having a dream
board i love the idea of seeing your
dreams every day
it's so important because otherwise
they're just in our heads you know
it was the single most critical part of
his success
is seeing his dreams and his goals and
his plan
every single day there was no getting
away from it
and when things got hard he always went
back to his dreams
wow and that's where i think most people
fall short they don't have a clear goal
they don't have a clear dream and they
don't have a plan and then they just
wander
with him he had one goal iron man
november
2020. he had three dreams his own house
his own car and smoking hot
blonde like his mom yeah and the rest
was just you know
every day one percent and that's it
that's his whole plan a big dream a big
goal and one percent a day
is that it chris yeah and um
before i go back home i'm going to
downtown nashville do you have lunch
i'm going to grab this market hop on
woman yeah oh look there's a lot there's
a lot of there's a lot of beautiful
women in this city
yeah so uh oh yeah we'll make it
a pretty rumor yeah we'll make it happen
we're all looking for a man
um chris and nick uh nikitch
sorry it's one of those names it's okay
it scares you every time i start it
um thank you guys for letting me be a
part of your life today
thank you thank you for inviting us this
has been amazing this is cool man this
is really inspiring and uh
and i just feel i honestly just feel
grateful to have been in you guys
presence thank you so much
it's our pleasure thank you for inviting
us and giving krista this opportunity to
share with your fans it's fun chris is a
cool guy
yeah yeah he is
you are a cool guy aren't you buddy yeah
i love being around
i'm the most
sassy classical yeah
the sexiest guy i love it are you really
yeah
yeah i'm the like the most
popular sexist so like
i'm the most populist
sexy man i was off you don't even know
what that means
but i like your attitude brother you'll
figure it out you know
i know what you mean he wants to be
sexy man have a sexy woman
we all want it man we're all looking
maybe he'll teach you something you stop
it oh you need somebody
you need like um maybe can you be like a
big brother and teach you stuff
yeah what do you think you want a big
brother who can seize yourself
that's cool we'll connect you got it man
we will we'll connect
chris thank you so much for being here
now i'm just floating
on the breeze and i feel like these
leaves i must be
[Music]
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a
[Music]
now
you